il s'appelle Timothée et il est né
allongé il y a trois mois mais il
n'existe pas administradi
administrativement un imbroglio juridico
administratif dont on parle avec notre
invité
Aurore carnoir bonjour
vous êtes la maman de Timothée
aujourd'hui ce que la naissance de
Timothée est enregistrée
toujours pas toujours pas bon on va
remonter un petit peu le fil de ce qui
s'est passé depuis trois mois on est le
2 juillet vous accouchez à votre
domicile par choix vous dites que c'est
pour éviter de revivre ce que vous avez
décrit comme des violences obstétriques
lors de vos précédents accouchements
seul le père de Timothée est présent et
le problème surgit en fait quelques
jours plus tard quand
le père de Timothée souhaite enregistrer
la naissance de de Timothée à la mairie
de Langeais qu'est-ce qui se passe à ce
moment-là
alors le papa il y va une première fois
pour déclarer un enfant il faut les
pièces d'identité des parents créer ou
compléter un livret de famille un
justificatif de domicile et une
attestation d'un témoin qui est présent
à l'accouchement là pour le coup c'était
le papa donc il y va avec tous ces
documents mon dossier de grossesse et
puis des textes de loi puisqu'on sait
que c'est un choix un peu atypique et là
il est confronté à un refus à plusieurs
reprises pour quelles raisons c'est quoi
le motif du refus c'est que la témoin en
fait médical
qui qui attestent de cette de cette
naissance
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez fait
derrière vous avez cherché peut-être des
des preuves médicales alors c'est ça
c'est à dire que on s'est dit comment ça
se fait qu'on puisse refuser une
déclaration en mairie peut-être qu'il
faut que l'officier d'état civil voit
qu'il y a une maman et un enfant qui est
pas une gestation pour autrui et donc
c'est pour ça que après on y va le bébé
le papa et moi
pour que là aussi il atteste de tout ça
et
refus à nouveau et on nous intimide on
nous menace de retraits d'enfants fait
appel à la gendarmerie qui verront qu'il
y a pas de troubles à l'ordre public
puisqu'on était très calme donc vous
repartez notre médecin traitant qui nous
fournit un certifié médical on donne le
certificat médical et ça ne marche
toujours pas
la PMI à la Protection Maternelle et
Infantile vous a contacté aussi vous
pensez que c'est en lien avec cette
affaire qu'est-ce qu'il voulait
alors la PMI en général quand ils
appellent c'est pour proposer leurs
services ou en tout cas présenter leur
service et là le rappel c'était est-ce
que tout va bien vous êtes sûr que ça va
bien un médecin dans les trois jours à
un peu inquiète une demande de
vérification aujourd'hui le dossier dans
les mains de la justice c'est ça c'est
le procureur qui qui enquête en fait
actuellement
on peut pas enregistrer Timothée auprès
de nos assurances donc s'il y a quelque
chose comment ça se passe on peut pas
l'enregistrer auprès de la Sécurité
sociale donc tous les frais de santé
Liette Timothée sont à notre charge et
puis ils sont au nom d'une entité
juridique qui n'existe pas
on peut pas le rattacher non plus à la
CAF donc on a pas de prestation sociale
et puis je peux pas reprendre le travail
puisque j'ai pas de moyens de garde ni
prendre un congé parental puisque je
n'ai pas d'acte de naissance parce que
il n'existe pas administrativement donc
je parlais du procureur de la République
parce qu'il y a cette enquête qui est
extraordinaire mais qui dans ces cas
précis vise à démontrer qu'en fait c'est
bien votre enfant quoi c'est ça un peu
l'idée que ça se c'est pas de la
gestation pour autrui un trafic illégal
illégal de de bébé il y a eu des
auditions qui ont eu lieu vous avez
entendu vous par la gendarmerie dans ce
cadre là oui dès la première semaine on
avait déjà fourni les documents liés à
ma grossesse et au post-partum au
procureur mais ça faisait trois mois que
ça bougeait pas et là enfin samedi on a
eu des auditions enfin des on a dû
fournir notre témoignage c'était
vraiment orienté sur la naissance et pas
tellement sur la déclaration puisque il
faut bien distinguer les deux il y a
d'un côté les conditions d'enfants non
et de l'autre côté une démarche
administrative on coche des cases elle
doit être elle doit être effective c'est
ce fameux document aujourd'hui pour
avoir le droit à tout ce dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
notre sujet illustre des choses beaucoup
plus grandes comme le corps des femmes
les violences obstétriques et
gynécologiques la place de la famille
les
signalements et retrait abusifs des
enfants la physique enfin les pratiques
hospitalières également qui sont pas
très respectueuses de la physiologie
enfin il y a d'autres familles on n'est
pas des cas isolés et je crois que c'est
un vrai sujet
un sujet dont on parlait en tout cas qui
qui vous empêche là pour le coup de
d'avoir le droit à tous devais avoir
droit